Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
July 16th,
2018 what's going on?
How was,
yeah,
how you doing? It's Sunday
afternoon when I'm recording this,
so I'm still in Seattle, Washington.
I've yet to do by shows up here.
I'm imagining that they're going to
go pretty well. Um, I was in Portland,
Oregon last night. Jesus
Christ. Great shows,
amazing people coming out. You know,
even though I tease them a little bit,
you know, I was making fun of
some of the people in Portland.
Do you know what I like? What really
amazes me about this generation,
or actually maybe like the,
I guess the past 10 years,
it's just the amount of shit that guys
do in their twenties and that like if I
did it back in my twenties I would
get the shit kicked out of me.
It's really unbelievable. Is
it bill, how about an example?
I'll give you an example. I was coming
over from Portland airport, by the way,
the first time I've ever landed here or
ever landed important one I should say,
where it was actually
just sunny and beautiful.
Like I believe my first
aborted landing I ever had.
MMM.
Wasn't Portland, Oregon. It was fucking
raining and the guy was coming in,
there was all this wind shear and then
he just fucking went up and around again
and we were all like, dude, what the fuck?
And I'm this old guy who was just like,
you don't take as many chances as you
need many times as you need or whatever.
It's like, just get this bucket thing
on the ground. Everybody kind of left.
So this was the first time that was way
back when I was working fucking happy.
It's comedy club down the street.
Um,
which is a really interesting gig cause
the guy who ran it back in the day,
you know,
he would paper the entire room,
which means he would give the show a way.
So you go in and on a Tuesday and the
place would be packed with people who,
you know, one, a comedy show, you
know what I mean? So it was weird.
It was like doing this giant office party
and you do one Tuesday, one Wednesday,
one Thursday to Friday,
three Saturday and then one on Sunday.
And uh, but the cool thing is I
got to hang in Portland all week,
check out all these cool
places to eat and now, um,
I kind of dip in and dip out. But
that's that, that's an old story.
So anyway,
so getting back to what the fuck I saw
it driving from the airport from Oregon,
from Oregon, from Portland airport over
into my fucking hotel. I swear to God,
I saw two guys in their 20s on a bicycle,
built for two.
And then behind the guy,
those two guys was another guy.
Do you remember those cars when you
were a kid? If he had like a toy car,
you got it, got in it right? It's made all
let them metal and then you pedaled it.
Yeah.
This guy had an adult version of that car.
I'm riding behind
the two guys on a bicycle built for two.
Now this might seem harsh
and I might seem old school,
but shouldn't they be getting
the shit kicked out of them?
I know in a perfect world they should
be able to do whatever makes them happy.
But there's just something about that VA
[inaudible] where you're so begging for
attention.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
You just can't get on a bicycle.
It's gotta be a bicycle built for two.
It's gotta be a little toy car and you're
a fucking adult in it with your God
damn hipster beard. Like, I dunno,
I'm really disappointed with the bullies
in the millennial generation. You know,
you're,
you're letting a lot of stuff slide.
Is he advocating bullying something?
Yeah,
a fucking spit ball.
Anything. I mean, I, I just,
I was in the middle of the
pack when I was in school.
I got bullied and I bullied some kids.
You know, I was right in the fucking bill.
You know, I was background. I
wasn't cool. I wasn't a nerd.
I was just one of those people
that filled out your class picture.
That's all the fuck I was, you know?
And I just felt like this pressure,
like that somebody is not doing
the job needs to get done.
Yeah.
I felt like sticking
my head out the window,
like fucking ogre in that
goddamn movie and just be like,
just something.
I mean,
how as an adult are you supposed to sit
there and talking to another adult with
a waxed mustache and
never fucking bring it up?
You know, I, I don't know
that shit. I Dunno. It's, it's
really is like, it's like how
okay
bored are you as a fucking person that
you have to like become like a character.
Like you go back and you watch a beer
commercial from the late seventies,
early eighties,
and then you just decide that
you're going to dress like that guy,
but she's still going to be your douchey
self, but you're going to have, you know,
his mustache and Hairdo and tee shirt.
It's really fucking weird.
I don't know.
Okay.
I Dunno. Just the shit
that bothers me. Um,
I'm having sort of a anger relapse.
I was doing so well
and the other day I snapped in the car
when this fucking person just, you know,
took them like nine tries to parallel park
and if actually felt
weird to yell in the car,
cause I hadn't in a good three weeks.
So I tried to get an in check,
but I think I let the fucking genie
out of the bottle. So I need to uh,
sit down and work on myself again.
Because today when we were flying
from Portland up to Seattle,
you know,
we were boarding
the plane
and um,
I was in the first group, you
know, after people in the military,
people with disabilities,
people with kids,
people with dogs that make them
feel like it's okay to fly.
Uh,
people with acne problems.
Like I don't know how many fucking groups
around now before group one boards,
group one is really like group 26
at this point, right? You know,
it's blue shirt Fridays. Anybody with
a blue shirt can now board anyway, so,
okay,
we walked out onto the tarmac to board,
right?
And I see this woman in front
of me, he has stopped, you know,
it's like when these deals where you
walk outside to get on the plane and
there's this little zigzag sorta ramp,
you have to walk up and she stopped while
this flight attendant is helping this
other woman up there. So I'm
thinking in my head, well you know,
she didn't tell me to stop so I'm
going to walk around this lady,
I was kind of being a Douche and I went
to walk around her and she fucking stuck
her hand out like that.
She told me to wait,
she kinda like hit me with their hands.
She did like the mother
thing and she was like
old,
like white hair and shit and like the
shit that went through my fucking head,
not initially when she hit me,
I was just surprised like what the fuck?
She just hit me.
MMM.
Oh my God.
The level that I judged her.
Okay.
I was like,
is that how you got up in the first class?
You fucking competitive cont you know?
Meanwhile,
I was going to walk around her and I knew
I was supposed to wait and I was being
a Douche.
I just kept playing it over my head that
I just wished I walked right through
her little fucking stiff arm
that she gave me. And um,
I ended up sitting behind her on
the plane and in my, my, in my,
my brain's telling me to hit the back
of her chair to rattle her head a little
bit, but you know, the, the, the
rest of my brain's going through it.
It's an old woman. Why are you
letting her get to you like this?
And then when we landed, I was
thinking like, she's not married,
just no fucking way any
guys putting up with her.
And then it looked and she had a
wedding ring and it was just like, uh,
the fuck is wrong with some somewhat
getting off the plane now we'll walk down
one of those ramps.
And I was actually laughing at myself
because I knew I was going to have to pass
her and get into the airport before her,
you know,
just to somehow make up for
that fucking moment. Right.
How fucking stupid is that?
And then I do it.
I turned around and
glance and look at her.
She doesn't even know that I exist and
I wasted all of that energy. You know?
It probably took probably,
I don't know,
40 seconds off my life
with that level of just,
you know,
it was like legit hate.
Like I hate this person.
I mean, I don't like,
so she, she fucking touch me, you know,
what am I, what are you supposed to do it?
You don't want me to just say,
Hey d yell at some Old Lady.
Get your fucking hands off
me lady. Ah, do it again.
You'll never make another
batch of cookies. I mean, what,
what exactly am I supposed to be
doing there? I just, you know,
I created that whole situation
and I've really, if I'm
honest, looking back,
I knew that she was flying first class,
so she was probably on some
level of lunatic and I,
and a control freak. And I kind
of knew that if I went around her,
it was going to bugger.
I just did not anticipate her giving
me the flare chop when I tried to go
pastor.
So I kinda got what I deserved.
Oh Man.
I can't believe how upset I let that
get me and I created the whole fucking
thing. I really am a pathetic
human being, but um, you know,
it makes for a good story.
You know,
it helps fill up a podcast sitting here
in the hotel room. Right. Oh, by the way.
So I'm at,
I'm in the airport,
we know before this lady gave
me the flare chop and, uh,
the World Cup final is like
happening and I'm taping it at home.
And it is so not a big deal
in this airport that I can
actually walk in public.
Well, the super bowl of the world
is being played and no one's,
there's no spoiler alert. Nothing.
No one had it on. It wasn't on,
on any TV. I didn't see anybody watching
the fucking game on their phone.
If I didn't go on Instagram, I wouldn't
even know who won this fucking insane.
But anyways, I guess
France one. All right.
Congratulations. What do they
say? I Lay, lay, lay blue, right.
I Layla blue, congratulations to
France and congratulations to Croatia.
A country of what? 4.1 million
people according to Pete Davidson
and his Instagram page, um, that they
got that far was fucking incredible.
Um,
and I knew I was going to be happy with
either person winning and I obviously
love France and, uh, Croatia was the
underdog, so I was rooting for them,
but I did not see the game.
I heard there was an own goal,
you know, fortunately he didn't
do that in South America,
so I think he has a chance when it
gets back to his hometown, but, uh,
they lost by two goals anyways.
What the fuck are you going to do?
But I did not see it. But, um,
I did in this world club become a soccer
fan and I've gone from not giving a
fuck to wanting to Google where the
next World Cup is going to be so I can
actually go.
Um,
and I'll go there with 40 other Americans
if our team makes it and will cheer
them on until they lose in
the first fucking round or
whatever the fuck happens.
Um, so anyways, I'm up here in
Seattle, Portland, and Seattle. Well,
you know, two of my favorite cities.
What are your favorite cities? Oh,
glad you asked a Portland,
Seattle.
I say Seattle over Portland,
you know?
Okay.
They're both nice. Portland just has a
little more of a hipster Douche factor,
you know, it was sort of a tie. And
then when I saw that guy in the bice,
the two guys in the bicycle built for two
with the kid with the Kitty car behind
it, I says, I was like, I fucking
can't. All right. You know,
and then you come to Seattle and you got
the new world order, hippies. I mean,
there's a lot up here to kind of be
annoyed with, but a beautiful cities,
lush land, all kinds of water. And
that's just amazing up here. Um,
San Francisco,
Los Angeles.
Okay.
Milwaukee, Minneapolis,
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
These are my favorites.
MMM.
Obviously I'm from Boston.
Uh,
Cleveland, Detroit, Buffalo, Pittsburgh.
MMM.
I think that's it. The rest of the towns
can all go fuck himself. Kidding. Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
What's,
what's my favorite one in Texas?
I'm going there in two weeks.
I'm going to fucking Houston,
Texas in July as a redheaded bald male.
The fuck was I thinking?
Houston. Dallas, San Antonio.
Austin college station.
Okay.
I Dunno. It's, they're
all kind of the same.
Okay.
It's flat.
This,
the most shiny is new pickup trucks
you've ever seen in your life.
I've never seen so many shiny brand new
pickup trucks in my four door pickup
trucks in my life.
They looked like they just,
they just got taken right
off the showroom floor.
MMM.
Can you hear my stomach growl? And by the
way, I'm having a steak dinner tonight,
so I just ate light like an hour and
a half ago. I had a soup and a salad,
fucking old bastard. Um, by the way,
I'm up to 70 pounds on the lat pull
down machine. Ah, you liked that?
The fucking rotator cup is a
rehab and a person helped me out,
told me I need to get up to about 120
pounds on that thing and I have to do it
really slowly so I don't fucking
blow up my shoulder again.
I've got one 20 then I can attempt to
do for pull ups and I'm back in the game
cause I have a bet with
Versie that when I'm 70,
I'll be able to do 10 of them and uh,
that's not going to be a fucking problem.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying. It's 50.
We'll see. That's a long 20 years man.
And I'll tell you all depends
on how I do it. You know,
if I live my life the way I did last
month, I won't be able to do to pull ups.
I don't even know if I'll
be around to do pull ups.
If I live my life the way I'm
living at this month, you know,
I might do 15 I'm crushing it.
This month was 16 days in,
Oh,
freckles hasn't had a drop of booze,
said shutting it down.
I shut it down for a month.
Give yourself a good fucking month then
ease myself back into my binge drinking.
I can't tell you this though. I have
never caught a fucking cold like this cold
that I caught in Minneapolis and into a
whatever the fuck I went after that to
Troy Jesus Christ.
This thing has been lingering.
I caught it on like June 30th and I was
sick for a week and now it's just been
lingering like, uh, I dunno.
I don't know if I need to lay off dairy
or something to get the last little bit
out of it.
Last night I was on stage and I started
like cough in my throat was getting all
fucking dry. I Dunno. I'm
sure you guys out there,
none of whom are doctors all have
a fucking reason why. You know,
maybe I'm just an old bastard.
Speaking of that,
speaking of being an old bastard,
I put the TV on and this hotel,
this hotel is really fucking annoying.
You know,
like I wanted to order room service and a
sec. Where's the menu? Where's the menu?
I can't find the menu.
So I called them up,
they got the men used on
the TV sound like, okay,
all right, well I'm not
going to get upset, you know,
but getting up to upset lately,
let's just,
this is the way the kids do it nowadays.
Let's do that. And I go on there, right?
And you know God damn well that the
fucking thing is on the TV cause it cause
they want you to solve. They want
you to order through the fucking TV.
So they have that information.
What's his name? Who is he?
How old is he?
What food does he eat?
We've gathered all of this fucking
information. What kind of porn?
Oh does he watch? Did he rent a movie?
All of this fucking inflammation,
that dimension that probably watching
you through that little fucking camera on
the TV too. And then they just bundle
it all together and they sell it.
So I didn't know where to throw the
TV I called instead that probably got
something connected to the phone. It's
just funny. It's fucking unbelievable.
I would, can you imagine if
you actually read the file,
okay.
You know on yourself that
these corporations have
like the amount of fucking
information that they have about you.
And if they actually kept
the video cause they'd been,
they've gotten busted watching people
in the, in their fucking houses,
watching people in their houses watching
TV. What if you're banging your wife,
you know?
Well if you're walking around fucking butt
ass naked, what do they do? This is it.
How is that legal?
It's unfucking real man,
these fucking nerds and making robots
that you can fuck the down there.
Fucking them at the factory trying
them out before they sell it to us.
You've got these other fucking nerds,
they're in the goddamn
watching your fucking,
your wife and there's barely a ripple,
barely a fucking ripple.
But as a comedian,
if you send out a fucking tweet
that steps on somebody's toes,
all of a sudden you ended it just
like this big fucking dustup.
If I ever get in trouble for a fucking
Twitter or anything like that's going to
be my defense. Hey, hey, hey, hey guys,
guys, guys, I'm not fucking a robot.
Okay?
I'm not bundling your information,
watching your bang and your
spouse through your fucking TV.
Let's have some priorities.
Huh Ladies?
I'm sorry.
Getting all fucking amped up here again.
You know? Uh, all right.
So anyways,
so I get it.
I put it on the TV to try to find
the fucking menu on this TV itself.
Like the only way you can
like change the channels,
you have to go back to guide and
then goes to, I mean, I came,
I can't even figure out the fucking TV.
Okay,
this is why I hate technology and why
it felt like somewhere in the 90s they
just should have stopped. Quality
of life was good enough, you know?
But this shit where it's just like
I always equated to reading.
It's like I learned how to read.
I didn't have to relearn how to
fucking read every six months.
But like with computers and TV and shit,
that's what it's like. It's like, Hey,
I know how to turn on a TV. I know how
to operate a TV. And then the next day,
oh wait, no, I don't.
Okay.
Now I have to waste time.
Relearning something that it'd be like
every time you've got your fucking car,
you didn't have to, every six months.
Now you don't know how to drive.
You have to learn how to fucking
drive again. We get a bill.
You don't like technology? No, I liked
it. I liked it to a point, you know,
central air conditioning, you know,
modern medicine and that type of shit.
But I mean, we were, we were all
fucking good right up until, I mean,
what did they really cured?
And the last fucking 20 years,
people still die of cancer.
People still go bald, you know?
Uh, you know, people
still get hammer toes.
Okay.
Actually they can fix hammertoes right.
Stop hammertoes boo Doo Doo Doo. Right.
They can fix those fucking things,
can't they?
MMM.
Anyway,
so I get into the fucking hotel here
and I saw this hilarious ad for this
shit called age ageless, ageless male,
you know,
and then like,
Hey,
what'd you get over the age of 40 your
testosterone levels go down and be, yeah,
cause you're too old to fuck.
Yeah.
Cause no one wants to see you with your
shirt off cause you fucking old and now
people are taking these
goddamn young pills.
Yeah.
You know you want to fuck
right into your eighties.
You want your Dick to stand at attention.
You want your balls to support the troops.
Okay.
Get this fucking ageless male. All these
fucking morons pumping all this extra.
Isn't that how you lose your fucking hair?
Isn't like a testosterone issue.
Like you have too much in there.
That's going to be fucking hilarious.
All these guys going for abs
that had a nice set of hair,
then they're going to go fucking balls.
Now they've got to get the fucking
hair plugs. It just never ends.
I bet the guys who make hair plugs also
make ageless male, you know, and they,
and they've gotten all the bald guys that
gave a fuck enough to get hair plugs.
So kind of like, you know, you reached
that saturation point like remember Crocs,
it's just they ran out
of Douche bags to find,
to buy those things,
which by the way, man,
I've been like I told you
getting rid of a bunch of shit
and um,
that's all I see stuff as. No, I
just look at it like that shit.
I'm just gonna have to throw out one day,
you know,
we walked through the airport deed Delray,
who fucking murdered last night murder.
You hear me?
Murder.
Okay.
He was pointing out some store at the
airport that sells records and all this
shit. He's like, man, he's like, dude,
that starchy hills, you know, detox.
He fucking kills man. People go in
there and I just looked in, there I go,
that is just a bunch of shit I'm
going to have to throw out one day.
Okay,
I'm done dude. I'm not
taking anything, you know.
Well, I did that show like last week, uh,
at the Hooters upstairs in the big room.
When I left,
they tried to get me a fucking hat and
a t shirt. Say I'm all set. Thank you
all good.
Don't need that lane
around the fucking house.
I got so many God damn jackets.
I don't know how the fuck I
have enough fucking jackets.
I could close every homeless person.
That's roughly my size in Los Angeles.
The amount of jackets I have.
And um,
does anybody in, is there a
coat drive? It's fucking July.
Once the next coat drive I'm getting,
I'm going to have one winter coat,
one fucking spring code and then fucking
some piece of shit when it rains.
That's it.
Yeah.
When the fuck did I become
coat guy? I, I can't,
I don't even know.
I think I have like fucking 20 coats.
Got All his sports shit.
I'm done with it. I'm done.
I'm telling you right now. I want
to fucking dress like Malcolm Young,
rest his soul the rest of my life.
Jeans and a fucking plane t shirt.
You gotta get the plain t shirt. I'll
tell you why, even though you didn't ask,
is you don't have any emotional
attachment to it, right?
If it says the Adirondack, she like, oh,
that's where I went on my honeymoon
when I banged my wife up in the fucking
mountains.
And you can't get rid of it,
but if you fucked her in a plain
gray t shirt, you're not. You're not.
You don't remember that.
And then you know what?
You get rid of it.
Yeah.
That's what it's all about. This
said, bull of fucking vegetable soup.
MMM.
That's the age I'm at now.
People,
I'm 50 years old and I order a
soup and a salad and I eat it.
And then right afterwards
I feel like I need a nap.
Which is why you need ageless male.
You don't age naturally die when you're
supposed to and get the fuck out of the
way. All right, let me, um, maybe read
some advertising here for this week,
shall we? Shall We? Let me
read some advertising here. Um,
hotel tonight.
Okay.
Hotel tonight is the only booking
app you need on your phone.
What would,
if you want to book some other Shit,
what a book of fucking
stripper for a party.
I would think if there's an app for
that, you know, anyways, hotel tonight,
partners with the top rated hotels to
help them sell their unsold rooms and
passes those savings along to you,
which means you get great deals for uh,
for great rooms.
Unlike other hotel booking sites.
Hotel tonight
to net two,
not to ne,
Oh, I'm good. Phil Collins Song.
Okay, good. I make get right
to night to night. You can't
tell me someone was in the studio
going like, I don't know if Phil,
I don't think that just sounds annoying.
It does not sound like a fucking hit.
Unlike other hotel bookings hotel tonight.
Nay, nay, nay.
Oh, doesn't it? There's no fucking way
I'm singing that for the rest of this.
I apologize. Doesn't, doesn't have long,
endless list of a zillion hotel choices.
Instead,
hotel tonight shows you only the best
deals at the best hotels rooms or
categorize to help you find the
room that's just right for you.
It's like a top shelf one.
Okay.
They're not going to let you know that
motel six has a fucking broom closet
available for $3 for the night that
you need another wrap for that.
You know that same app,
you can probably get a bag of meth to
go into that fucking hotel. Hips, solid,
basic luxury, luxury. Get the rum.
You're looking for it in the right place
at the right price in the 11th hour,
but it's not just for
last minute bookings.
It's perfect for planners
as well as procrastinators.
I just realized I'm going to a big,
I'm going to the Michigan.
I think I'm going to go to Michigan,
Wisconsin at the big house this year.
I need some hotel rooms.
Browse your destined desired area with
map few searching and get inspired to
travel. Perfect for spontaneous
weekends, three day getaways.
Staycations the greatest vacation you'll
ever take. Road trips, business trips,
booking a hotel so you can use the pool,
et cetera. Download the hotel tonight.
Tonight.
APP Toy
at. Oh, they kind of ran
out of the copy here.
Where do I download it? It doesn't say,
it says download the hotel tonight.
App Toy at toy,
at and with Promo Code Bur bur you can
get the $25 off your first eligible
booking hotel tonight. Promo Code
[inaudible]. All right, that's what it is.
Hotel tonight, Promo Code
Burr. Hey hotel tonight,
Promo Code Burr staycations the best,
but this is what you do.
You don't tell anybody.
You know that you're staying home.
You tell everybody you're going overseas
and that your phone isn't going to work.
Then you unplug your home phone and you
stay at home. You stare at the wall,
put on a bathing suit and you fucking
drink a bottle of booze. Okay,
that's living. All right.
Oh, look who's back. Old Zip.
Roberta
hiring used to be hard man.
Multiple jobs sites,
stacks of resumes are confusing.
Review process,
but today hiring can be easy and you
only have to go to one place to get it
done.
Oh,
zip.com/burb ZipRecruiter's sends your
job to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards, but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technologies,
zip scans, thousands of resumes,
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them and invites
them to apply to your job.
As the applications come in,
ZipRecruiter analyzes each one and spots,
lights the top candidates so you
can never miss a great match. Zip
is so effective that 80% of
employers who post on sip
get a quality candidate through there to,
to their site within the first day.
With results like that,
it's no wonder Zip,
Eh,
the highest rated hiring site in America.
And right now my listeners can try exam.
Yeah,
for free
at the exclusive web address,
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's
ziprecruiter.com/burr one more time,
a zip.com/burb
zip recruiter. The smartest way to
hire, oh look who's here, but Oh,
don't do me undies.
Me undies.
Look at Y'all fucking Dick do
to do to me undies, me undies.
It's hanging down nice and quick. Wouldn't
it be nice if you had some more balls.
Get some testosterone
and fuck at the mall,
a male and some colorful underwear,
and then your fucking back in the
game. As a World War II veteran, um,
you've definitely heard
me talk about me on these,
you know the fun comfy undies and feel
as good as they look to those of you who
haven't tried them yet.
Listen Up.
You can get incredible underwear
sent to your door with me undies,
meaning no more hunting around for the
perfect pair with a crowded store and
eventually sending
settling for good enough.
Me undies are made with a sustainably
sourced material from beechwood trees.
This underwear is made out of wood,
evidently in somehow it's
still nice against your
bulls. They're naturally soft.
Fiber makes a fabric that won't sag down
or write up unless you balls hang low.
Okay? You can't blame the
underwear, that shoe junk. Trust me.
Once you put on a pair, you'll get
it. Feel free to improvise here,
but what you love about me undies,
oh, I love the colorful way.
My nuts glow when I walk across the
room with a pair of me on these.
And if you're already part
of the Mondays family,
tell your friends about it
through their referral program.
They'll get you a discount and you'll
get a store credit. It's a win win.
Still not sure. Well me undies
has a deal for my listeners.
First Time cartridges purchasers can get
50% off their first pair of me undies
and free shipping.
That's 15% off plus free shipping and a
guarantee that you and your me, Andy's.
We'll be happy to get a kid see me
jerking off in other underwear except this
beyond these. Get your butt over to me on
[inaudible] dot com and treat yourself.
Um, do you get 15% off your first pair
of free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee?
Go to me undies.com/ [inaudible] that's
[inaudible] dot com slash Birch Jesus
Christ is still two more.
Let's give,
let's give you guys a break
for me reading out loud.
Okay,
I'm going to go to our first question
here. Okay. Eastern European tour.
Uh,
good afternoon on the July 9th,
2000 18th podcasts and around 28 and a
half minutes in bill briefly mentions and
eastern European tour.
I was trying to locate specifics
on this and wasn't able to, uh,
to do so.
Do you have any information on this or
is it just a pipe dream at this stage?
Thanks. No, it's a real fucking tour.
Let's see here.
I don't want to name cities.
All right. Because I don't want
to get people all, you know,
thinking then I'm coming
in and then I don't,
okay.
Let me just see what I can do here.
Let me find a fucking email. Okay.
Why does it, why does it anything
with technology work for me?
Why can't I get up to the fucking
search bar here? There we go. Okay.
MMM.
Okay. Looking for Eastern
European tour, a bird,
a European tour. Oh no,
that's the other thing.
Come on, man. This was
supposed to be easy, man.
Okay.
All right. Dollar Shave
Club. Press itinerary.
Yeah,
no subject.
Is it this one?
Okay. These are the ones we were,
we were thinking about doing.
Okay.
I'm not going to say him because I
don't want you guys to get all fucking
excited and then I don't go.
All right. One of them rhymes.
Oh, is a hard one to Brian.
Um, uh, with Luda pest.
Another one,
Brian's with Rog.
Another one rhymes with a Sienna
for saw aunt Berlin.
Maybe I'm going to do Jeremy,
maybe Cologne, Slovenia,
Brussels.
Um,
and I think we're going to add some more
to that. I mean, it's maybe going to,
it's going to be in those areas.
Okay. Because here's the deal, dude.
If I get close to your fucking country,
you know,
just jump on a fucking train to go
over once your papers please. You know,
I mean, how fucking far am I supposed
to travel yet? Cons. We'll see.
We'll work it out. But I mean, I want
to do more dates than that. So, uh,
we'll see. And this guy, interestingly
loved, says Poland wants you
do your bill. My husband and I
have been fans for many years.
We love the podcast and of course you
specials and all the Larry's and creative
content that all things comedy is
putting out. Great stuff. Look at this.
All things comedy appealing to people
around the world, world, world, world.
Um, that's why we're crazy. Excited
about your upcoming Easter European tour.
We live in Europe,
uh,
Germany and Poland and think you should
consider Warsaw Poland as one of your
stops. There's a pretty lively English
language standup comedy scene here.
I love it.
Checkout a worldwide comedy,
facebook.com/worldwide comedy and
twitter.com/whatever the fuck that is.
Something about Warsaw for
some information. The food,
beer and vodka are great.
Oh
yeah,
you had me at beer and vodka.
Um,
you'll see the scars of World War Two
and Soviet occupation all over the place.
For example,
on the city streets and highways.
Driving can be a serious hazard.
A driving with bill special edition
episode would be really funny.
Okay.
I could possibly do that.
Um,
for some reason they wrote WRL like
roar claw is a great university.
I taught the civil war,
so wrong. Roar claw.
Okay.
He's a great university city
with an awesome history,
which we know interests you.
It used to be called Breslau and it was
one of the Nazi strongholds at the end
of World War II.
You can Google fet Sung Breslow or
CG of Breslov for some of the insane
backstory. I will definitely
be doing that. Uh, in fact,
the Nazis evacuated the city
as the allies were approaching,
they evacuated the citizens to Dresden,
Germany,
where they were mostly all
killed in allied firebombing.
Yeah, in Dresden. Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Whoever lost World War II was going
to be tried for war crimes. Um,
there was all kinds of evil done in that.
Also,
this is one of the cities where the
solidarity movement started in 1980 which
contributed to the collapse of
communism. Oh, I remember that guy.
That guy with the big mustache.
He,
he got you guys all mobilized over there.
I forget the guy's name.
Plus there were like 400 dwarf
statues hidden all around the city.
Weird but cool. Anyways, we hope
you'll consider adding Poland's.
You're eastern European tour. We wish you
the best. Thanks for the great content,
uh, you and the ATC network
or putting out we love it. Ps,
your name and Polish would be
either the hick or the solution.
Ah, fuck I can, I can eat.
Just buy those names alone.
I can hear the fucking weight.
Then I'm going to fucking be
putting on when I go over there,
I can't wait to do it.
I've never been there.
Um,
you know
I'm going to talk to my uh,
okay
to my agent again on
Monday about this shit.
I mean I might as well do as many as I
can. When the fuck am I ever going to be
back. All right. And uh,
so here's the deal.
I'm going to go over there and all
I need is you can't spend a show up,
all right?
Cause I know the over there eating some
fucking bratwurst and fucking Poland in
front of three. God Damn people going.
Where were the ones that sent the emails?
Nobody else gave a fuck.
All right. Legal Zoom, everybody
becoming a successful business owner.
It doesn't just happen. It
takes hard work. God dammit.
You hear that ladies with all your bitch
moaning and complaining about how easy
guys haven't even legal zoom
knows you got to work hard.
I don't give a shit
what's between your legs,
so quit your crying strap
that Bra and and get to work
and you really can't afford to
let anything get in your way.
So when it comes to all the details and
regulations she needs someone that has
your back,
that's someone is legal.
zoom.com legal zoom was
created 17 fucking years ago.
Their mission is to help
all Americans confident,
confidently and completely navigate
the legal system. Since then,
over a million people have trusted
legal zoom for business information,
but your relationship with
legal zoom hardly ends there.
They put together a network of independent
attorneys licensed in every state
available to answer your questions and
provide legal advice for your business
without billing by the hour.
Since legalzoom is not a law firm,
because as a business owner,
you have enough to worry about without
getting bogged down with the legal stuff.
Man for that.
There's legal zoom.com.
Go to legalzoom.com now and use the
Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout for
special savings, legal zoom where
life meets legal legal zoom.com.
Yeah.
Um, and lastly, but not
leastly movement watches.
Mvmt you guys have heard
me talk about movement.
Okay.
You know those two college dropouts
that started their own watch company
movement watches start at just
95 bucks at a department store.
You're looking at four to
500 bucks movement figured
out that by selling online
they were able to cut out the middleman
and retail markup providing the best
possible price.
Classic design,
quality construction in styled minimalism,
minimalism,
movement, watches are all about looking
good and keeping it simple. Man.
Movement watches don't tell you how many
steps you've taken or blow your wrist
up with text messages,
parentheses you up.
Uh, it tells that that's probably the
worst example they could have done.
Cause that sounds like you're
going to get late. Uh, it,
it's time and it looks good doing it
tells time it looks good doing it.
If relevant.
Talk about how smartwatches is overly
intrusive on life with notifications,
text messages, email, et cetera. We, I
mean, you already have it on your phone.
Yeah,
right. It's like redundant. It's a hat on
a hat. As they say in the writer's room.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to movement.com.
mvmt.com/burr.
See why movement keeps growing.
Checkout they're expanding collection.
Go to m the m t.com/burr.
Join the God damn movement.
Okay.
I was actually going to order
a movie, hit him and the, uh,
the hotel room here and for whatever
fucking reason they want 24 99.
Yeah.
SECC has nobody's going
to the movies anymore,
so they're trying to make back the
fucking budget of the movie. Um,
I actually worked on a movie this week.
Okay.
Written by and directed by
the one and only Steve Byrne.
You got me a couple of days on his movie.
An old freckles went down there and,
uh,
I played a cunt, so it wasn't much
of a stretch. I wasn't really acting.
I just sort of did what
the fuck I normally do. Um,
anyways,
do you want,
the great thing about not drinking is
aside waking up fresh as a goddamn daisy.
I mean, my freckles glow when I
wake up when I'm not drinking is
okay.
I got on the plane and I landed
and I went down and I worked out.
Yeah.
And then took a fucking steam and
I'm knocking out my podcast here.
I would not have done this.
Granted,
I don't have any crazy stories
about going into bars and shit,
which of feeds the podcast,
you know,
but at some point I just have to
make a decision here. You know,
am I going to wake up sober
with a less funny podcast or
am I going to keep boozing
and continue to crush the podcast game?
No kidding.
Um,
I actually have no idea where
my podcast is in the overall I,
all these fucking people that do
podcasts like I'm the number one fucking,
but they been like,
everybody's fucking number one.
Everybody has a million fucking downloads.
I don't want to get it.
How can everybody be number one,
everybody's in the fucking top 10.
Then I had this guy on as a guest and
it put me in the top down and fucking
active.
Um,
anyways, what the fuck
was, I just look it up.
I want to look up that shit about
the fucking Nazis to World War II.
The, the, the fucking crimes
against the shit that you read.
Like the shit that American troops to,
I read this fucking thing and this guy
shot this Japanese soldier and like eat
the guy couldn't like fucking move.
I don't know if he's like paralyzing.
He had gold teeth and the dude was still
alive and the fucking guy took a knife
out, was digging the gold teeth out
of the guy's mouth while he was alive.
And the dude was screaming
in agony and the other,
another American soldier went up and just
shot the guy like Jesus Christ put him
out of his fucking misery.
Crazy.
You know what I mean?
But everybody makes movies and everybody
on one side is fucking evil and
everybody else, dude, you can't,
you can't be involved in that shit
with the people go fucking nuts.
You know?
Especially all it is is just,
I would think that once like hook out
mad I got at that fucking old lady who
gave me the flare chop.
Now imagine if I was man enough
to join the armed services,
right? Armed Forces, whatever
the fuck you call him.
And I'm out there on patrol and I
see one of my friends get killed.
Like what kind of fucking moody you
going to be in after that? You know,
it's fucking insane and I swear to God,
the more I watched the discovery channel
and the more I watched chimpanzees
behavior, I swear to God,
just watch those fuckers.
Watch what the fuck they do to each other.
I watch what they do to other monkeys and
shit. I'm telling you telling you this,
that's what we are. Whenever I watched
shit on TV, I put send these for years.
I just always think of this
fucking documentary that I
watched these chimpanzees
and like 10 of them ganged up on
the southern chimp. They fucking
fuck this thing up.
Did horrible things,
agonizing things to this monkey killed it.
Then afterwards they were all fucking
amped up and it was like they were all
talking shit about what they
did in the fight. So whatever.
I watch shit on TV and I see like,
you know,
Trump talk in this shit or that fat
fuck there in Korea run in his fucking,
I swear to God, he looks like
a giant piece of fucking you.
Every Toros Sushi. It's like from
the softest part of the tuna,
like melts in your mouth.
Like God helped that guy.
If he's ever in a plane crash that lands
in a snowy mountain and they got to
start eating people because that
guy is going to be a prime cut.
It's all fucking marbled. You know, he's
the boss's son. He's never done shit.
You know,
isn't it funny that he walks around
that army outfit and he's like fat?
You know?
Was that when you go to the,
you know,
those fat people that always wear workout
clothes, that old joke. Um, anyways,
here we go. Let's read another one
here. Uh, Africa, a Billy freckled fuck.
Longtime Fan. Love your work,
blah, blah, blah. Listen,
I know you're planning on touring eastern
Europe next year we got another one.
Uh, but how about a tour of
South Africa? At some point,
if you and the lovely Nia ever managed
to make your way to this side of the
world, please don't hesitate
to contact. Also, always know,
always wanting to know if you are friends
with Bryan Cranston or not do to your
time together on breaking bad.
Thanks so much. And Go fuck yourself.
Ps when he going to be on Kona.
Again, a lot of questions. All right,
let's start with Africa.
I love to go over there and I
could tell you this right now.
There's no way I would go on one of
those fucking safaris in that open car.
As those lines walk up looking
at you. I know they, they,
they say that like those lions,
like they look at the car and the
person all is like one giant thing.
So that's why they don't just don't jump
up and just yank somebody off to truck.
Well one of these days,
one of those lines is going to figure it
out and they're going to yank somebody
off the truck and it ain't gonna be
fucking me. I can tell you that right now.
Do you ever see that fucking video?
Is that uh,
that poor woman as an Asian family,
she didn't want to,
she was driving through the safari.
She didn't want to drive and she got
out and walked around the car and I'm
telling you, man, this tiger comes into
frame frame and grabs her and yanks.
Like I couldn't Yank
like
dish rag out of frame
faster than this thing.
Took this 115 pound woman out of the
frame and then like her son or something
that didn't know what to do in this
fucking hero ran over there and then he
ended up getting killed. And the other
is mom got like mall or something.
It was fucking brutal.
Fucking brutal.
So I know you probably laugh and go and
film, you know, we have cities over here.
It's not just a bunch of Lions and
tigers fucking walking around. I know,
but I'm just saying the touristy
thing to go go over there. Your,
you basically your zoo is the jungle.
Unless I'm crazy.
I Dunno. Anyways. Um, what was the
other thing I always wanted to know?
If you are friends with Brian Crane?
I'm friendly with him.
The few times I've run into him.
Have I run into him since breaking bad?
I don't think I have during breaking bad,
I ran into him at a party
with a mutual friend.
Um,
yeah.
And I don't remember ever,
I don't ever remember us coming to blows.
So I would say that we are
very friendly, but we, uh,
we don't hang if that's
what your question is. Um,
what am I going to be on Conan? And
again, I don't know, hopefully soon.
I fucking love Conan. I love South
Africa and in love. Bryan Cranston. Me.
He went three for three
here. All right. The crazies.
Yeah.
Uh, the crazies. Hey Bill,
the crazy little thing about you getting
called the Republican Douche is that I
see just as many people on reddit and
Twitter accusing you of being a liberal
softy. Yes. And all of that is, is,
is just more evidence
of what a contact him.
All right. What? I'm in La, I make fun
of Hilary. What? I'm in a red state.
I make fun of Trump,
you know,
I don't understand being in front of a
group of people and just saying what they
already think.
Like where is the fun in that?
Say The opposite of what they think and
make them mad and see if you can get
them to stay. Right. Anyways,
it seems like people just attack and
focus on only one thing they care about.
As you always say, as you
always say, I love you,
congratulate on Royal Albert Hall. It's
my dream to play trumpet there. Thanks.
To go fuck yourself. I hope
that dream comes true. Yeah. Um,
yeah,
I've been accused of,
yeah.
It all depends on what, what the
argument is. Yeah. I think, um,
yeah, I've been called a
red pill eating Republican.
I've been called
a liberal liberal,
a charge snowflake,
cut cold, all of that shit. And
I've been called a centrist.
I love the centrist one. Like,
isn't that the smart one?
Well you kinda in the middle. You lean
a little bit. I lean left. I think I do.
Anyway. So it all depends on
who the fuck I'm talking to.
It depends on how far left you are.
Um,
how far right you are. You probably
think I leaned way left. I don't know.
But a centrist did. Somebody like,
I don't know. I can be swayed.
You know,
you present a good fucking argument.
Yeah.
You know,
take a guy like Ted Nugent.
I don't agree with a lot of this
shit that that guy says, but he does.
He does say Shit on occasion.
I'm like that. I agree with,
I just don't write people off 100%,
you know?
And I also don't think that I have all
the fucking answers. So if that makes me,
I don't know what the fuck that makes me.
He says centrist. Do you realize
how fucking Douchey that is?
That adults literally have to like it
come up with a label?
Everything.
What that really means is you don't
think the way I think and I can't fucking
handle it.
So I'm going to come up with a word that
is going to have some sort of negative
connotation. And I think you're so
weak as a person that it will affect,
I don't give a fuck what I really don't
give a shit. You're a centrist. Am I?
Okay. All right. You're a liberal
snowflake. Yeah. Okay. All right.
You're a Trump supporter for, how
can I find five? There you go.
Now go yell about that
to somebody at work.
MMM.
Anyways, documentary about
origin of soccer. Oh, by the way,
I learned more about
that World Cup trophy.
Somebody sent me this thing on Twitter.
Okay, so there's one World Cup trophy.
Okay.
And you're not allowed to have it
because it's worth like 20 million bucks.
So if you win it you,
they actually give you a replica of it.
This is what this person
was trying to tell me.
I don't know if any of this is true.
And then somebody else told me
that if you win like three of them,
you actually get to keep the fucking
thing in Brazil cast one and then they had
to make another one now rather than just
telling you guys shit that I've heard.
I could actually look up World Cup trophy.
Yeah.
Which I can't believe how small it is.
Okay.
It's ridiculous. World Cup, trophy
history. Here we go. Ah Right.
And I'm going to click on it.
Let me do what everybody does.
When you search something.
MMM.
On the fucking Internet is you just take
the first, what the fuck is this thing?
Where the hell did this? Just
take me. Have you noticed now?
Like they just gives you one option.
You know they're paying,
people are paying for that.
Look at this.
It keeps taking me the same fucking site.
World Cup trophy,
his story search,
Google,
come on.
Yeah.
Keeps taking me this fucking website.
I'm not going to name the name of it.
Look at that. It just fucking
kicked me off. You fucking cons.
How much did they pay?
I can only go to U World Cup
trophy and a triple trophy
history search. Google.
There we go. All right.
It was a fucking glitch or something.
The World Cup is a gold trophy. Oh,
it's actually made out of gold.
Ours is fake shit and wonders are so big.
Like the Stanley Cup is made
out of fucking aluminum.
Stainless steel maybe, uh,
is a gold trophy that is awarded to the
winners of the FIFA World Cup associated
bumper. Bubba. Since the advent
of the World Cup in 1932,
trophies have been used.
The jewels rimet trophy from 1930 to
1970 and the FIFA World Cup trophy from
1974 to present day.
The first trophy originally named victory
bell later renamed in honor of Fifer
President Jules Rimet,
or is that use remat?
I have no idea.
Was made of gold plated,
sterling silver and Lapis Lazuli Zuli,
whatever the fuck that is as depicted
and depicted Nike, the, the
Greek goddess of victory. Oh,
is that what the sneaker company has?
I didn't know that.
Okay.
Wait,
let's do a quick little aside here.
Okay.
In ancient Greek mythology,
okay.
Nick was a goddess who
personified victory.
Her Roman equivalent was Victoria.
She was variously described as the
daughter of the titan upon the gods.
This system, uh, uh, I, I have no idea.
I had no fucking idea.
Look at that.
Learning something that'd be even
bill can learn something. Anyways,
Brazil won the trophy outright
in 1970 prompting the,
the commissioning of the
replacement. Well, why did it,
how did they win it outright? They
just want it so many times like, hey,
just give to these fuckers with
second carton it across the world.
The original Jules room at trophy was
stolen in 1983 and never recovered.
What?
Yeah,
there's only one pro that's a drug.
Lord,
something fucking Pablo
Escobar had that or something.
The subsequent trophy called the fight
for World Cup trophy was introduced in
1974 made an 18 carat gold.
Yeah.
With is something basis, Dan. Okay,
now wait a second. Wait a second.
Okay.
World Cup trophy stolen.
Maybe it wasn't so fucking small. They
couldn't have stuck it under their shirt.
The theft of the jewels rimet trophy.
It was stolen in 1966 prior
to the 1966 world cup.
The trophy was later recovered. One man,
I thought they said they didn't get it.
One man, Steve Cook, a Barista
was convicted for being involved,
but other possible culprits is still a no.
You can't tell me that
guy's not a fucking legend.
Yeah.
Trophy place in a, how come that
hasn't been made into a movie?
Some sort of fucking comedy. What was
he some jerk off from a sports bar.
The football associated received
the cylinders. It's a theft.
On the March 20th Sunday,
March 20th when the guards began a noon
circuit around 1220 they noticed that
someone had forced open the display case
and the rear doors of the building and
stolen the trophy.
The wooden bar that held the trophy that
held the door closed was lying on the
floor.
That's all they had to stop them.
These removed the screws and the bolts
that held the other side of the door.
Okay.
They went to Home Depot and
bought some screwdrivers in,
stole the biggest sports trophy in the
fucking world. What is simple time?
They had removed the pad lock
from the back of the display case,
taking the trophy and
left the way they came.
None of the guards had seen or
heard anything suspicious though.
One of them reported that he had seen a
strange man by the public telephone when
he had visited the laboratory on the
first floor is those guys were fucking
offer Scotland Yard took control of the
case and gave it to the flying squad.
The flying squad?
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
Sounds like a musical.
The flying squad also known as the robbery
squad is a bunch is a branch of this.
Okay.
The serious and organized crime command
did an eight year old name all this shit
with London's metropolitan police raw.
Is this serious?
It's not the,
it's not the frivolous crime command.
This is this serious and organized
crime squad purpose is to investigate
commercial armed and unarmed robbery is
along with the prevention investigators.
Who gives a fuck.
Sounds like they have uniforms.
Yeah.
Oh, then somebody, oh, that's
somebody. Actually they
ransom for the fucking thing.
On March 21st Joe Mirrors the chairman
and the football section received an
anonymous phone call.
The unknown man said that mirrors would
receive a parcel at Chelsea football
club. The next day the parcels
delivered to mirror his home.
It contained the removable lining from
the top of the trophy and a ransom note
that demanded 15,000 pounds
in $1 a one in five pound notes.
The letter stated that the FAA,
the FAA should place a code coded, add,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
Okay.
Uh, despite the warnings that
mirrors contacted the police
detective Charles Buggy of the flying
squad and gave the trophy lining and the
letter to him, police told mirrors
to place an ad and contacted a bank,
created a false ransom payment out of
bundles of ordinary paper with real money
only at the top and the bottom,
which replaced in a suitcase to police
officers were to act as mirrors,
assistance and handing over the money
and went to Home Depot. Okay, so mirrors
was suffering from an asthma attack.
So his wife answered instead and
gave the phone to assist it. Mcphee,
oh,
McPhee Jackson was nervous,
but finally agreed to arrange a switch
and told fee to come to all you fucking
moron. And then he got caught.
But it isn't that something.
You see that you'll learn something
every god Damn Day, don't ya?
What a fucking dope.
Yeah.
It should have just kept the
God damn thing. Then you can't,
what are you gonna show your friends?
They're going to fucking open their
mouths trying to get laid. All right. Um,
anyways, documentary about the
origin of soccer. Hey Bill,
you're talking about the origin
of soccer last podcasting,
and I want to give you a recommendation
to watch wild in the streets.
It's the re the origin of all
football, including rugby,
soccer, and your football.
It is lit literally a type of
rugby played by an entire town,
north versus south.
The entire city is the field they play on.
Well worth the watch,
especially for sports fan.
I found it on Amazon fire slash
fire TV. Have a good day. All right,
I'll try to check that out. Lastly,
but not leastly classic movies.
Dear Billy dollars.
After he talked about La Mons last month,
I decided to watch the movie.
I really loved it.
I never knew I needed to drive
through Europe till I saw that movie.
I'm 22 and the first thing I noticed was
how differently it was pays compared to
the schizophrenia stuff I grew up with.
It was very calming in a way.
I was wondering if you could recommend
any good movies from that era.
I'm going to keep watching McQueen movies,
but I was hoping you could give more
titles from the era so I don't burn out.
Okay.
All of, all of his at once. Um,
you can't go wrong with Steve McQueen.
You can't go wrong with Paul Newman. Um,
obviously Paul Newman, you got
to, I would watch the hustler.
MMM.
I liked Hud. What else? Um,
cool hand Luke. Uh, Steve McQueen.
You got to go and you'll Brenner.
You gotta go magnificent
seven Cincinnati kid bullet.
MMM.
And for those of you,
before you go see the rock movie,
go watch the towering inferno.
If you watch the towering inferno
and then you watch die hard,
I think you'll see those two are
combined when they sold that movie,
this the new rock movie as I feel
like it's those two movies combined.
MMM.
Wow. I haven't thought
about movies in a minute.
What else did I like from back
then I liked all the clinics.
Would Spaghetti Westerns, loved Charles
Bronson, anything with Lee Marvin and it,
uh, the dirty dozen bridge on the river.
Kwai Kelly's
heroes.
MMM.
The greatest scape,
speaking of which,
do you know when I did Steve Burns movie,
the character that I'm playing at one
point is potting golf balls in his office
and somebody connected with the movie
was friends with the James Garner estate.
Speaking of the greatest scape and
the [inaudible] was James Garner,
scold potter and I, it was fucking
unbelievable. Cause you know,
I always watch me TV and the Rockford
files is one of my favorite shows of all
time.
And I love it even more than I did when
I was a kid because I never understood
like,
I think losers too harsh a word,
but like how much this guy was
struggling in life. He lived in a,
on a trailer on the beach.
He had the Firebird,
he didn't have the money for the trans-am.
Okay.
And he couldn't sustain a relationship.
I mean the guy was a mess.
He didn't like to fight.
I mean it was just fucking funny as hell.
MMM.
It's another one that I love,
but I am right now I'm just burning
through that 77 sunset strip with Efram
Zimbalist Jr. I just can't
get enough of that show. Um,
it's just, it's that classic shit
where anytime a woman comes on screen,
they play that fucking saxophone music
man. It's just fucking hilarious.
F from smoking and like every other scene.
And I,
and his drink is a, he likes
an old fashioned ry. And,
uh, like back then when they were
building a character, like they had,
they have their drink and they had
to have a car and Efren symbolist his
character in 77 sunset strip is,
uh,
he favors afford thunder
bird convertible and he big,
and I even wa I've only seen season six,
so I think that was in 1963
or 64 Thunderbird convertible.
But I went online and I watched the intro
to all the different seasons and, um,
he seems to have late fifties ones
because it ran from like 57 and 63.
It was like six seasons
or something like that.
So it'd be cool if I'm watching it and
he gets a new Thunderbird every year
convertible. Um, and once
again, the restaurant,
uh,
this office that he's coming out of his
Dean Martin's Dino's that old restaurant
that he had and, um,
which was on la Cienega.
It was on sunset boulevard at the corner
of last Anegada on the southwest side
of the street.
MMM.
40 fucking Badass.
Anyways,
I'm an old man and I got
two shows to do here. Um,
thank you to everybody that
came out to Portland last.
I had such great shows and thank you to
everybody who's coming out to my shows
tonight and Seattle and this
is one of my favorite cities.
And I think the next time I come here,
I'm going to try to do like
what I did was in San Francisco.
I'm going to play a smaller venue and
just be here for a week and I'm gonna
bring my wife and kid up here because,
uh,
the lovely Nia always wanting
to go to Seattle and I've,
I've never brought her
up here. And uh, I dunno,
it's a shame cause it's so fucking close
and it just never seems to work out
with their schedules.
So I think next time I might do a,
one of my favorite theaters in the
country, which is the more theater,
which for you rock fans,
that's where Alison chains shot
that black and white concert film.
That's where pearl jam shot that video.
You know,
we had a better climbed up the side
and dropped down into the crowd.
Pohanka could get get to down.
Wham. A couple of partner
Pamper Africa now, right?
Remember that's some, um, all right,
that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
Congratulations to France. Went in the
World Cup. Congratulations to Croatia,
England, Belgium, all you guys
that got down to the final four.
It's fucking incredible.
It's an incredible thing to watch and I
hope to go the next time there's a world
cup. I'll check in on
you on Thursday. See it.